[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
روسيا تستهدف كيا بصواريخ كروز وبريطانيا
تقول ان يمنع مسؤولين كبارا من الاستقاله
امين وعام الجامعه العربيه للعربيه قمه
جده تشهد عوده سوريا كعضو كامل العضوي في
المنظمه
انباء عن معارك شرسه وقصف بالطيران بمناطق
جنوب الخرطوم والمساعده الانسانيه تتدفق
وزير دفاع طالبان يعترف لا قدره دفاعيه
لنا لمواجهه المسيرات التي تسيطر على
اجواء افغانستان
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نبدا النشطه بتطورات
الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث افادت وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه ان خط لسكك الحديديه في جزيره
القرم قد تعرض لاستهداف ادى الى وقف حركه
القطارات يحدث هذا في وقت دوه انفجارات
عده فجاه الخميس ومناطق اوكرانيه اخرى حيث
ناشدت السلطات السكان الاهتمام في الملاجئ
حسبما اعلنت الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه
وقال رئيس الاداره المدنيه والعسكريه في
كييف انه تم تسجيل سقوط حطام في منطقه
التحقق من البيانات الخاصه بالضحايا
والاضرار
[موسيقى]
ياتي هذا مشاهدينا بعد ساعات قليله من
اعلان وزاره الدفاع الروسي انه تم تدمير
بيان انه ووفقا لبيانات مؤكده وموثوقه
ونتيجه للضربه الجويه بصاروخ كينجال الفرض
الصوتي تم اصابه وتدمير محطه رادار متعدده
الوظائف المنظومه اضافه الى خمس منصات
اطلاق صواريخ امريكيه الصنع يذكر ان الجيش
الاوكرانيه يمتلك في الوقت الحالي منظومه
زودت الولايات المتحده كييف واحده منها
اما الثانيه فارسلتها المانيا وهولندا
وتبلغ قيمه المنظومه الواحده نحو مليار
دولار
حذيفه عادل ومن دون اس كمراسه العربيه
رائد الاغوار اهلا بكم
هذا الهجوم والضرر الذي نجمع عنه ايضا في
العاصمه اخرى في اوكرانيا فجر هذا اليوم
نعم تحياتي احمد في الحقيقه 16 مدينه
اوكرانيه تعرضت لعمليات قصف من قبل القوات
الروسيه من طبعا من ضمنها العاصمه اكيد
منذ التاسعه مساء الامس وحتى الان هنالك
30 ضربه صاروخيه وجهت نحو الاراضي
الاوكرانيه استطاعت القوات الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني ان تسقط 29 صاروخا من اصل 30
صاروخا ايضا اسقطت طائرتين مسيرتين وكذلك
طائرتين من طراز اورلاند اعطائره استطلاع
ايضا تم اسقاطهم هذه الحصيله بشكل عام
طبعا لم تحدد اداره اكيد عن عدد الصواريخ
التي وجهت نحو العاصمه ولكن تم اسقاط جميع
الصواريخ التي استهدفت العاصمه كيف حطام
سقط في منطقه صلوبسكي وفي عدد من المناطق
سقطت بعض من الشظايا لا يوجد اي اثار تذكر
هنا في العاصمه كيف طبعا الضربه اثرت حيث
تم استهداف منشاه صناعيه قتل شخص واصيب
شخصان في اوديستا كذلك في نيكا لايف كان
هنالك ضربه استطاعت ان تصل الى هدفها
وكذلك في خارجك حيث قتل ثلاثه اشخاص وفي
خرسون كذلك قتل طفل يبلغ من العمر سته
سنوات هذه هي حصيله الضربات الصاروخيه
وراجمات الصواريخ بشكل عام نفذت القوات
الاتحاد الروسي في 24 ساعه الماضيه 101
مئه وواحد
منجمات الصواريخ ونفذت اكثر من 42 غاره
جويه في معظم الاراضي الاوكرانيه من ضمنها
طبعا خط التماس انتقل لك رائد وابدا معك
ايضا من مساله الهجوم الذي طال السكك
الحديديه او خط سيف الحديديه في شبه جزيره
القرم وربما نجم عنه ايضا التوقف لحركه
القطارات ما الذي توفر المعطيات او
معلومات حتى اللحظه حول هذا الهجوم
احمد نهارك طيب وحذيفه ايضا بالفعل هناك
عده ملفات عدا عن ما يحدث في شبه جزيره
القرمو هي الضربات الروسيه على المدن
واهمها اديسا ايضا
عوده
القصف الاوكراني على مقاطعه مدينه دنيسكو
وضواحيها تحديدا وصول الاسلحه المتطوره
الى ايدي القوات الاوكرانيه الجانب الروسي
يتهم اوكرانيا بان هجماتها المرتده هي
عباره عن عمليات ارهابيه تتهم الجانب
الاوكراني بتنفيذ عمليات ارهابيه مستمره
تصفها بالارهاب وهي تستهدف المدنيين
وتستهدف البنى التحتيه مثل ما حدث في
القرن وتفجير قنبله او لغم على سكك حديديه
ما ادى الى يعني انحراف القاطرات عن
مسارها ولكن ليست هناك اضرار بشريه حسب
المعطيات من هناك من هذا وذاك الاوضاع
والتطورات هنا في دانياسكو وبعجال سنقول
بان الوضع في باخمت بات قريبا
لانهاء المعركه في باخمت يقول بان المتبقي
هو حوالي عشره بيوت في اخر المدينه
المنطقه الغربيه
وسيطرت جيش الروسي او قوات فاجنر على 260
مترا اضافيا في العمق الغربي وتقول القوات
الخاصه من هناك بانها دعمت المحاور او
الاجنحه التي تقدم فيها جيش الاوكراني
لتعزيز قدرات الجيش الروسي البشريه من
الناحيه الشماليه والجنوبيه وان يعني
اعلان السيطره الكامل على مدينه باقمت
ربما سيتم خلال اليومين القادمين او اكثر
من ذلك لكن بشكل عام الاسلحه المتطوره
التي وصلت الى ايدي القوات الاوكرانيه بات
لها تاثير كبير ارتفع خطيره القصف
الاوكراني على المدينه هنا وصلت الى حول
400 قذيفه وصاروخ خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه
خمسه قتله وعشرات الاصابات استخدام صواريخ
هايبرز استخدام قذائف يعني ام تربل سفن من
مدافع هاوزر استخدام الصواريخ البريطانيه
الحديثه ستورم وايضا هناك صواريخ خارمه
التي تطلق من الطائرات او المقاتلات
الغربيه هناك بالفعل محاوله يعني
لضرب مواقع ربما تكون عسكريه لكنها تصيب
مواقع مدنيه
في منطقه
تتحدث معه وترتدي كامل زي كانوقائي ايضا
يعني هل من توترات امنيه في هذه المنطقه
التي تقف فيها الان
بالتاكيد التوتر الامني لان القذائف
والصواريخ تصل اذا يعني حسب
التقييم
للسلطات المحليه كل خمسه دقائق يسقط قذيفه
او صاروخ في مناطق متفرقه من المدينه
وضواحيها وهذا يجعلنا بالفعل يعني نتخذ
كامل اجراءاتنا الوقائيه في هذه المنطقه
الساخنه جدا او الاكثر سخونه في الاقليم
وفي يعني ارض المعركه وحتى في العالم احمد
بالفعل منطقه دانياسكيا الاكثر سخونه
بالعالم من حيث المعارك وسقوط القذائف
والانفجارات وكل ما تعنيها الكلمه من معنى
الحرب نعم نتمنى لك السلامه رائد الاغبر
من دونيس كنت معنا مراسله العربيه
والسلامه ايضا لحذيفه وجميع الزملاء من
مراسل العربيه امريكي تحياتي لكما رائد
وحذيفه
مشاهدينا قالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان
روسيا تمنع مسؤولين كبارا من الاستقاله
على الارجح تزامنا مع استمرار الحرب في
اوكرانيا واضافت الدفاع البريطانيه في
تقييد لها ان المنعه يشمل على اقل قاده
المناطق ومسؤولي الامن والرئاسه كما اوضحت
انهم من المرجح ان يكون العديد من
المسؤولين متشككين للغايه في الحرب مشيره
الى ان منعهم ياتي عبر تلميحات لهم بانهم
قد يواجهون اتهامات جنائيه ملفقه في حال
استقالتهم
صار اليوم وفي المقابل المشاهدين قال
مسؤول دفاع امريكي ان نظام الدفاع الجوي
للتقنيه المقدم لاوكرانيا تعرض لاضرار
خلال هجوم صاروخي على كيف لكنه لا يزال
يعمل حيث اشار الى ان واشنطن تعمل حاليا
على تقييم الاضرار المحتمله التي لحقت
بالنظام الدفاع الجوي رافضا الادلاء بمزيد
من التفاصيل وفقا لما نشرته صحيفه
فرنسا خطوه كبيره في اتجاه زياده القدرات
القتاليه للجيش الاوكراني فبعد 24 ساعه
لاستقباله
رئيسه ستزود اوكرانيا بالصواريخ ومن جهه
اخرى اعلنت المانيا استعدادها لتسليم
اوكرانيا اكبر حزمه عسكريه منذ بدايه
الحرب التفاصيل مع الزميلين حسين قنيبر من
باريس ورغدب همام من برلين نتابع هنا في
باريس التي زار هذا ليسكي بعد روما وبرلين
وقبل لندن كان ابرز ما قاله ماكرون امام
ضيفه ان فرنسا سترسل المزيد من الصواريخ
الى اوكرانيا لكن الاهم من ذلك قول الرئيس
الفرنسي ان مدى هذه الصواريخ سيكون ابعد
من مدى تلك التي ارسلتها باريس سابقا الى
ما سيمكن هذه الاخيره بحسب الرئيس الفرنسي
من الشروع في شن هجومها المضاد على الجيش
الروسي فرنسا ستقوم ايضا بتاهيل طيارين
عسكريين اوكرانيين وهنا
التعليقه حول امكانيه الربط بين هذه
الخطوه واحتمال ارسال باريس يوما ما
طائرات مقاتله الى كييف وسيرسل الفرنسيون
ايضا المزيد من المركبات المدرعه
والدبابات الخفيفه ومنظومات الدفاع الجوي
تقول باريس ان هدف تكثيف دعمها لاوكرانيا
عسكريا دفاعي لا هجومي
عندما دخلت روسيا الى اوكرانيا خرقت ميثاق
الامم المتحده الاوكرانيون يدافعون عن
انفسهم ولذلك تعطيهم فرنسا السلاح روسيا
بلد يعتدي في كل الاتجاهات لا يمكن اجراء
حوار معبوت الذي يسعى الى اجتياح الدول
المجاوره ووضعها تحت سيطرته الدعم الفرنسي
لاوكرانيا ياتي في سياق دعم اوروبي واسع
النطاق تقول باريس انه قد يعدل موازين
القوى العسكري لصالح
هنا استقبل المستشار الالماني قبل بضعه
ايام الرئيس الاوكراني
بحضوره عن اكبر حزمه مساعدات عسكريه
تقدمها برلين لكياف منذ بدايه الحرب بقيمه
ثلاثه مليارات دولار امريكي لتصبح المانيا
بذلك ثاني اكبر مانع عسكري لاوكرانيا بعد
الولايات المتحده حزمه المساعدات
الالمانيه الجديده تضم 30 دبابه ليوبارت
كانت ترددت المانيا بالموافقه على تسليمها
ما تسبب بتوتر العلاقه بين الطرفين الحزمه
الضخمه الجديده تطم ايضا 20 ناقله جنود
مدرعه من نوع اضافه الى اربعه انظمه ايروس
المتطوره المضاده للطائرات المساعدات التي
قدمت الى الجانب الاوكراني هي مساعدات
للدفاع والاستعاده على الاراضي الروسيه
التي الاوكرانيه التي تم استحلالها
احتلالا من قبل الجانب الروسي بمعنى اخر
لم يتم اعطاء او لم يتم الموافقه على
اعطاء طائرات هجوميه او صواريخ هجوميه حتى
ان تلك الانظمه الصاروخيه التي اعطيت الى
الجانب الاوكراني لا يتعدى مداها ال 120
كيلومتر اسلحه المانيه جديده يامل الرئيس
الاوكراني ان تساعد على بدء الهجوم المؤجل
لدفع القوات الروسيه على الانسحاب
عقب زياره المبعوث الصيني لهاي للعاصمه
الاوكرانيه
في بيان عن استعدادها لتشجيع المجتمع
الدولي على ايجاد اكبر ارضيه مشتركه لحل
الازمه الاوكرانيه
مشاهدين اضاف ايضا انها لاعب دورا في
تخفيف ورقه الوضع الانساني في اوكرانيا
وانها ستواصل تقديم المساعده في حدود
قدرتها
بدوره قال وزير خارجي الاوكراني
تقبل اي مقترحات لانهاء الحرب مع روسيا او
خساره اوكرانيا او تعليق الصراع مشددا على
ضروره احترام وحده اراضي وسياده اوكرانيا
كما اشاد كونيبا بدور الصين في جهود انهاء
الحرب مع روسيا الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
مشاهدينا قالت في بيان ان كوليبا شرح
بالتفصيل للممثل الصيني مبادئ ارساء سلام
دائم وعادل يستند الى احترام سياده
اوكرانيا وسلامه اراضيها
افاد مراسل العربيه باقتحام 400 مستوطن
اسرائيلي لباحات المسجد اقصى صباح اليوم
بحمايه مشدده من الشرطه الاسرائيليه
ويتوقع ان يشارك عدد من اعضاء الكنيسه
الاسرائيليه لاحقا في عمليه الاقتحامات
هذه يحدث هذا فيما يسود التوتر في القدس
وجوارها استعداد لمسيره الاعلام التي
تنظمها جماعه يمنيه متطرفه الشرطه
الاسرائيليه مشاهدينا نشرت اكثر من ثلاثه
الاف فرد من قواتها في القدس لتامين
المسيره
هذا وقت حمت قوات الاسرائيليه ايضا مدينه
نابلس في الضفه الغربيه فجر اليوم واشتبكت
مع فلسطينيين ما اسفر عن اصابه العشرات
بجروح ونقلت وكالته معا للانباء عن احمد
جبريل المتحدث باسم الهلال الاحمر في
نابلس استخدام الجيش الاسرائيلي للرصاصي
المعدني المغلف بالمطاط وابهر الصور على
الانترنت اطلاق الجيش الغاز المسيل للدموع
في حواري البلديه او البلده القديمه
[تصفيق]
مباشره مشاهدينا من محيط المسجد الاقصى مع
مراسله العربيه لعنا اهلا بكلانا وهل ما
زالت توتر سيد الموقف في باحات الاقصى
التي بدا اقتحامها منذ صبيحه هذا اليوم
اسرائيل هي رفعت حاله التاهب في القدس منذ
البارحه قامت ايضا باغلاق بعض الطرق او
سوف تقوم فعليا باغلاقها ايضا منذ بدايه
الساعه الثانيه ظهر اليوم لتامين مسيره
الاعلام التي ستسير من القدس الغربيه الى
القدس الشرقيه ايضا قامت فعليا او ستقوم
فعليا بايقاف القطار الخفيف وايضا نشرت
اكثر من 3000 جندي وشرطي فعليا في القدس
الشرقيه وايضا القدس الغربيه وفي انحاء او
علاء ابواب المسجد الاقصى المبارك منذ
صباح اليوم كما ذكرت كان هناك اقتحامات
كبيره من قبل المستوطنين فعليا للمسجد
الاقصى والمبارك على شكل مجموعات على
الاقل كان هناك عشر مجموعات اقتحمت في
صباح اليوم وارتفع اعداد المقتحمين الى
820 مقتحم وابلغ وقبل قليل فقط كان هناك
ايضا مشاركه من قبل نواب في الكنيست
واعضاء من الكنيست من حزب الليكود وايضا
من حزب القوه اليهوديه وهو
الذي ينتمي اليه ايضا اعتمر المتطرف
الاعلى بالنسبه للاسرائيليين ولماذا هذا
الاصرار دائما على تنظيمها رغم ما يرافقها
من توترات امنيه ومن كلفه باهضه ايضا
لتامينها
مبارك وكان هناك ايضا تحذيرات من قبل حماس
وجهاد الاسلامي انه ان تم هناك اي تغيير
بمسيره الاعلام بمسار هذه المسيره والدخول
الى المسجد الاقصى المبارك سوف يكون هناك
يعني صواريخ على ما يبدو تنطلق من قطاع
غزه نحو اسرائيل مباشره من محيط المسجد
الاقصى كنت معنا مراسله العربيه لناكل
غاصي شكرا لك لا على كل ما تفضلت به
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
بواسطه ترحيب بعوده سوريا القاده العرب
يبداون التوافد اليوم لحضور قمه جده
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد افاد مراس
العربي باورود انباء عن تجدد قتال عنيف
وقصف بالطيران في مناطق جنوب العاصمه
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
هذا خبر عاجل الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي يصل الى جدي المشاركه في القمه
العربيه بالعوده الى سياق النشاطنا
المشاهدين ظهر رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان وسط عدد من جنود
القوات المسلحه امام مقر قياده القوات
البريه في الخرطوم ويعد هذا احدث دخول
لرئيس السوداني بالرئيس المجلس السيادي
السوداني منذ بدء اشتباكاته مع قوات الدعم
السريع ويذكر ان مبنى قياده القوات البريه
يقع في محيط مطار الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قبل ظهور امس مشاهدينا لم يظهر البرهان
الا ثلاث مرات منذ بدايه الاشتباكات وجميع
ذلك في غرف مغلقه الاول حينما ظهر اثناء
عمله في غرفه العمليات ثم التهنئه بعيد
الفطر ومره الاخيره اثناء حضوره
الاجتماعات قيادات عسكريه
[موسيقى]
قال مستشار قائد قوات الدعم السريع للشؤون
السياسيه يوسف عز ان حميتي مستعد للقاء
البرهان في اي زمان ومكان يختاره الوسطاء
بشرط وقف اطلاق النار مشيرا في نفس الوقت
لان الدعم السريع سيطر على النحو تسعين في
المئه من مناطق الخرطوم وانا الحرب
الدائره دخل لها عمل دعائي دعائي كبير من
قبل الطرف الاخر ونفع عزت على هامش لقائه
برئيس جنوب السودان
نفى الاخبار المتداوله بشان استخدام دعم
السريع المواطنين كدروع بشريه
هذا واعلن الامين العام المساعد لجامعه
دول العربيه حسام زكي ان رئيس مجلس
السيادي وقائد الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان لم يمثل بلاده في القمه العربيه
المقرره يوم غد في مدينه جده السعوديه
وقال زكي انما سيمثل السودان في القمه
مبعوث رئاسي موفد من قبل البرهان وبحسب
مصادر دبلوماسيه فان قائد القوات المسلحه
السودانيه لن يحضر القمه كونه لا ينوي
مغادره البلاد لاسباب امنيه
والى مدينه بورسودان بولايه البحر الاحمر
غربيه السودان حيث لا يزال يتوالى
من مختلف الدول فمن المقرر ان تصل اليوم
مطار بورسودان الدولي اولى مساعده
الانسانيه المقدمه من الهند للاسهام في
دعم الموقف الانساني والصحي في السودان
هذا وكانت كل من السعوديه ومصر والكويت
والامارات وقطر وعدد من عدد من المنظمات
الدوليه سياره خلال الايام الماضيه جسورا
جويه الى بورسودان تحمل عشرات الاطنان من
مساعدات بهدف ايصالها لالاف السودانيين
الذين تضرروا بفعل الحرب
من دون مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الصحفي في
مكتب العربيه في السودان شهد نادر اهلا بك
شهدي واليوم الحديث عن اشتباكات دارت في
جنوب العاصمه الخرطوم بين الجيش السوداني
واخواد الدعم السريع هل ما زالت هذه
الاشتباكات مستمره حتى اللحظه وما اخر
المعطيات الميدانيه
نعم احمد هذه هذه اللمبه هي انباء مؤكده
حدثت اشتباكات تم تنفيذ قصف جوي في جنوبي
الخرطوم وتحديدا في مناطق
مناطق حي جبر الكائن في جنوب في جنوب
مدينه الخرطوم استهدفت القوات الجويه سلاح
الجو السوداني استهدفت المركزات لقوات
الدعم السريع هناك باستثناء ذلك تشهد
الخرطوم حاله من الهدوء الحذر كان هناك
طيران يحلق صباحا اتجه الى جنوب مدينه
الخرطوم نفذ قصفا جويا ولكن في مجمل
المدينه تشهد هدوء حذر اصوات متقطعه احمد
لاصوات مضادات من مناطق
بعيده اليوم يكاد يكون يعني هو يوم هادي
يوم على غير العاده التي حددنا ان يبدا
الى الطيران التحليق بكثافه خلال الساعات
الاولى من الصباح طيب شهودي ظهور البرهان
يوم امس في امام قياده القوات البريه في
القياده العامه كيف كان صداع في داخل
السوداني وابرز الرسائل التي مررت من خلال
هذا الظهور
نعم هذه المقاطع احمد لقيت رواد كبير تم
تداولها بكثافه شعبيا واعلاميا خبراء
عسكريين احمد اشاروا الى انها جاءت لتاكيد
لتاكيد ان النقائد لتاكيد انها اكدت لجنود
القوات المسلحه ان القياده معهم في خندق
واحد انها لن تبارحه كما ظلت اتاكد هذه
هذا هذا التجول احمد بحسب خبراء عسكريين
تحدثوا معهم انه سيكون له مردود ايجابي في
نفوسها
في نفوس جنود القوات المسلحه المنتشرين
كما انه حمل الرساله بان منطقه القياده
العامه هي مؤمنه بشكل يسمح للقياده العليا
ان تتجول وان تتفقد
القوات المرابطه في نطاق التامين داخل
داخل خارج القياده العامه كما تعلم مع
احمد ان مبنى القوات البريه الذي
ظهر غيث الجيش متجول فيه هو يقع داخل
الحرم القياده بجوار مبنى وزاره الدفاع
وبعده مبنى رئاسه حياه الاستخبارات وكذلك
عن شماله مبنى للقوات الجويه ومن ثم
القوات البحريه هو حمل الرسائل بان الموقف
هناك مؤمن بشكل اتام نعم شكرا الصحه في
مكتب العربيه في السودان تحيه شهدي
مشاهدينا قبيل انعقاد قيمه العربيه
الثانيه والثلاثين في مدينه جده غرب
السعوديه غدا الجمعه سيبدا اليوم الخميس
وصول قاده وزعماء الدول العربيه الى جده
حيث ستشهد المدينه لقاءات جانبيه تجمع عدم
قاده وزعماء الدول العربيه على هامش القمه
العربيه التي تاتي استضافه السعوديه لها
وسط ظروف الاستثنائيه تمر بها المنطقه
والعالم وتعمل من خلال هاجمعه الدول
العربيه والقاده العرب على مواجهه
التحديات المشتركه وتعزيز الامن
والاستقرار الاقليمي
وفي مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال الامين
العام جامعه الدول العربيه احمد ابو الغيط
ان خطوه اعاده سوريا الى جامعه الدول
العربيه هي سعي عربي لتسهيل عمليه حل
الازمه في سوريا عوده سوريا
عوده في سياق
ساعه عربي لتسهيل تسويه الوضع السوري سميه
الوضع السوري سمير اشكاليه السوريه
والحكومه السوريه والحكم في سوريا قابل
بان تكون هذه العوده في سياق بحث في كيفيه
وبالتالي في كيفيه
وبالتالي
العرب طرحوا نفسهم
اساسا
لمساعد للحكومه السوريه
للتوصل الى بر الامان او البر الاستقرار
او
ترحيب الكبير بعوده سوريا الى حضنها
العربي وبمشاركه دمشق في القمه العربيه في
جده الارشادات تركها تطلعات لان تلعب
سوريا دورا فعالا في الجامعه مثل ما كانت
من قبل
سنوات عجاف بلغ عدد اثنتي عشره سنه رفرف
خلالها العلم السوري واحدا ثم جاءت السنه
التي اغيثت فيه العلاقات السوريه العربيه
ليتوسط العلم السوري اعلام باقي الدول
المشكله للمنظمه من جديد الموعد قمه جده
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان رحب بمشاركه الوفد السوري في دوره
القمه العربيه الثانيه والثلاثين
وانتهز هذه الفرصه للترحيب بمشاركه
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعنا
اليوم
ترحيب كبير من دمشق بالعوده للحضن العربي
السعوديه بدلت جهد هائل من اجل تحسين
الاجواء العربيه ومن اجل
احتضان جميع الدول العربيه ونحن ممتنون ان
كل الدول العربيه الان موجوده في هذه
القمه المقعد لم يعد شاغرا وسوريا ابرز
الحاضرين
ترحب الجزائر ايام ترحيب
ببوادر تكريس هذا التوجه
الذي بدات تتجلى
ملامحه مع استئناف الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه الشقيقه شغله مقعدها بمنظمتنا
عوده تنظر منها الجامعه تفاعلا سوريا بناء
وايجابيا وفق ما جاء على لسان الامين
العام احمد ابو الغيط واتمنى ان تكون
استعاده سوريا لمقعدها مقدمه لانهاء
ازمتها
والاستعادتها لحيويتها وحضورها في العمل
العربي عوده سوريا الى حضنها العربي اهم
حدث قبل انعقاد القمه قمه ينظر اليها
مراقبون باعتبارها فرصه لمناقشه ابرز
القضايا التي تهم المنطقه العربيه بلال
البجدين العربيه
ومن مقر عقد القمه العربيه في دورتها
العاديه الثانيه والثلاثين في مدينه جده
غرب السعوديه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربي اهلا بك عبد المحسن
وتابعنا قبل قليل خبر عن وصول الرئيس
المسيعب الفتاح السيسي هل كان اول
الواصلين ومن يتوقع وصوله ايضا في الساعات
المقبله
[موسيقى]
نعم بالفعل احمد كان الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي وهو اول الواصلين الى جده
قبيله يوم كامل من اعتقاد القمه العربيه
الثانيه والثلاثين في جده ويتوقع ان يصل
القاده تواليا خلال اليوم وايضا يوم الغد
للاستعداد لحضور هذه القمه في جده بعد
ايام ثلاث سبقتها من الاجتماعات التحضيريه
المكثفه التي حضرها مندوبو بالاضافه الى
وزراء خارجيه ومسؤولون من كافه الدول
العربيه الذين شاركوا في هذه الاجتماعات
في الحقيقه احمد اجواء ايجابيه بشكل عام
تسبق هذه القمه انعكست بشكل كبير جدا على
الحضور الكبير
سواء كان الوفود الدبلوماسيه وفود وزراء
الخارجيه الذين اكتمل عقدهم الا من قليل
حيث قال ذلك الامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه يوم الامس بان هذه القمه للمره
الاولى ربما تشهد هذا الحضور الكبير من
وزراء الخارجيه في الاجتماع التحضيري الذي
كان يوم الامس والذي كان قصيرا وقال
مسؤوله الجامعه العربيه بان
الاجتماع كان قصيرا نظرا لان الملفات تم
التوافق عليها بشكل كبير جدا نظرا لاجواء
الايجابيه للتطلعات الكبيره التي تشهد هذه
القمه وبذلك تكون انهت الجامعه العربيه
وكذلك الاجتماعات التحضيريه كافه
التحضيرات ووضع الملفات الرئيسيه على
طاوله القاده يوم الغد ليتم تناول اهم
القضايا السياسيه المتعلقه بالمنطقه
العربيه بالاضافه الى القضايا الاقتصاديه
وربما للمره الاولى يتم تناول القضايا
الاقتصاديه باريحيه كبيره جدا حيث كان في
يوم قبل يومين اجتماع اقتصادي حضره وزير
الماليه السعودي قال بان السعوديه تتطلع
لان يكون هنالك نمذجه ونموذج لعمل عربي
موحد اقتصادي تتطلع فيه السعوديه لان يكون
هنالك
عمل عربي مشترك اقتصادي من خلال نماذج
اقتصاديه مشتركه ما بين الدول العربيه
وجامعه الدول العربيه بالاضافه طبعا الى
الملفات السياسيه
الدائره حاليا ومنها الازمه في السودان
سيتم تناولها سياسيا واقتصاديا بالاضافه
الى ملف الكبير ايضا عوده سوريا للمره
الاولى بعد تعليق تجميد عضويتها في جامعه
الدول العربيه وربما هي نتحدث عن هذه
الزياره التي اكدها وزير الخارجيه السوري
فيصل مقداد عن زياره الرئيس السوري
للسعوديه لحضور هذه القمه وهي الزياره
الاولى منذ
2010 عندما كان الرئيس السوري قد زار
الرياض في ذلك الوقت يزورها مجددا في جده
لحضور هذه القمه بالاضافه الى وفد سوري
كبير جدا سيحضر هذه القمه ووفود اخرى توقع
ان تصل خلال الساعات القادمه ويوم
الغد أحمد شكرا عبد المحسن على هذه
الاحاطه وسنكون معك في متابعه هذا اليوم
من مقر انقاذ القيمه العربيه في جده كنت
معنا مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
والان مشاهدينا نتابع معكم هذه الصور التي
وصلت قبل قليل لوصول الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي الى جده المشاركه في القمه
العربيه في جده في دورتها الثانيه
والثلاثين اذا هذه الصور لوصول الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي الى مدينه جده
السعوديه للمشاركه في القمه العربيه التي
تاتي وسط التحديات قديمه وجديده وتطلعات
تحقيق نتائج مهمه وملموسه على مستويات عده
في دوره في القمه العربيه في دورتها
الثانيه والثلاثين التي تعقد اذا في مدينه
جده السعوديه
وفي اخر تطورات الملف التركي مشاهدينا
اشدد كمالك زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري على
عدم السماح العقليه التي سهل الدخول عشره
ملايين مهاجر غير نظامي الى تركيا بالبقاء
لاداره البلاد مشيرا الى ان حزبه سيقاتل
حتى الفوز بالانتخابات حسب تعبيره
اخاطب الجميع لم نجد هذا الوطن في الشارع
لن نترك وطننا للعقليه التي سمحت بدخول
عشره ملايين مهاجر غير نظامي بيننا ايها
الشباب انهضوا وتخلصوا من ذلك الياس الذي
يخيم عليكم اولئك الذين يحبون وطنهم
سياتون الى صناديق الاقتراع سنقاتل حتى
النهايه وسنفوز بالتاكيد
على الجانب الاخر قال الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان انه واثق من الفوز بالجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه
مشيرا في الوقت ذاته الى بل مشيرا الى ان
المعارضه التركيه لا تمتلك رؤيه واضحه
واثقوا من الفوز بالجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات وبفارق كبير كيليكس دار اوغلو
تعرض لضربات كثيره اكثر مما راينا وكما
نقول دائما مشكله المعارضه بتركيا انها لا
تمتلك رؤيه او برنامجا او مشروعا لقد
غيرنا كل شيء في بلادنا لكن للاسف لم
نتمكن من تغيير المعارضه لكننا نعتقد ان
هذه الانتخابات ستؤدي الى التغيير الذي
ينتظره الجميع منذ سنوات
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
روسيا تستهدف كياب صواريخ كروز وبريطانيا
تقول ان يمنع مسؤولين كبارا من الاستقاله
امين وعامل الجامعه العربيه العربيه قمه
جده تشهد عوده سوريا كعضو كامل عضوي في
المنظمه
انباء عن معارك شرسه وقصف بالطيران بمناطق
جنوب الخرطوم والمساعده الانسانيه تتدفق
لبورسودان
وزير دفاع طالبان يعترف لا قدره دفاعيه
لمواجهه المسيرات التي تسيطر على اجواء
افغانستان
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اكد رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابقا ان الشرطه
حاصرت منزله مؤكدا انها ان مساله اعتقاله
امر وشيك خان كتب على حسابه في تويتر انها
انه ربما تكون التغريد الاخيره له قبل
اعتقاله مؤكدا ان الشرطه طوقت مقر سكنه
هذا وكانت السلطات الباكستانيه القت القبض
على خان الاسبوع الماضي في قضيه فساد قبل
ان تفرج عنه محكمه بكفاله حيث ان القبض
عليه اثار احتجاجات عنيفه في انحاء البلاد
اسفرت عن مقتل ثمانيه على الاقل
تخطط وزاره الدفاع الامريكي لاستخدام جيل
جديد من الطائرات بدون طيار فوق افغانستان
استهداف الارهابيين حيث قامتاغون ان مختبر
ابحاث القوات الجويه الامريكيه سيجد
الاختبارات على الطائرات بحلول يوليو
المقبل واضاف انه يجب ان تكون هناك مراقبه
على الاراضي الافغانيه بشكل مستمر خاصه
لاستهداف مواقع ارهابيين الذين يخططون
لهجمات ضد المصالح الامريكيه
اجواءنا محتله وهم يحلقون فوق رؤوسنا لقد
رايت ذلك بعيني وحتى انتم شاهدتم ذلك
وكذلك شاهد الوزراء والمسؤولون والقاده
والجنرالات العسكريون ننظر الى السماء
ونراها ولا نستطيع فعل شيء هذا امر مخجل
ومؤسف حيث انه خلال 20 عاما للحكومه
السابقه لم يحاولوا تعلم كيفيه صناعه
قذيفه او رصاصه واحده بالرغم من توفر كل
الموارد والالات ولكن هذا هو حال
افغانستان اليوم
اطلقت منظمه حقوقيه مقرها بريطانيا خريطه
تفاعليه توثق انتهاكات حقوق الانسان منذ
استلاء طالبان على افغانستان وتحذف
المنظمه عبر ما اسمته خريطه الشهود الى
لفت الانتباه الى تصاعد الانتهاكات ضد
المدنيين والصحافيين والاقليات العرقيه في
جميع انحاء البلاد حيث كشفت المنظمه في
الخريطه اكثر من 1300 نقطه بيانات للحوادث
منذ 17 من اغسطس 2021
واستخدمت فيها بيانات ومعلومات مفتوحه
المصدر للتحقيق في انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
وجرائم الحرب
فاطمه عظيم احدى الطبيبات اللواتي تم
توظيفهن حديثا في اكبر مستشفى لصحه الطفل
في البلاد لا يمكن تشغيل قسم الصحه بدون
مشاركه السيدات كما تقول فاطمه
عبر منافسه عامه اجرتها وزاره الصحه بين
الممرضات والطبيبات استطعت ان افوز ل
التحق هذا مستشفى قبل سته اشهر وانا الان
اعمل في جناح الاطفال الذين احترقت
ابدانهم لسبب او اخر
تزعم الصحه الافغانيه انه خلال العقدين
الماضيين لم يتم ايلاء الاهتمام المناسب
لتدريب والتوظيف واحتياجات الطبيبات
والممرضات وان الوزاره بصدد استخدامهن
وتقديم خدمات افضل لهن
عمليه استخدام الطبيبات والممرضات ما تزال
مستمره في جميع المناطق التي تحتاج اليهن
ويتم اختيارهن عبر عمليه شفافه بالتاكيد
الطاقم الجديد من الطبيبات والممرضات تقدم
لهن رواتب وامتيازات مناسبه
الصحه الافغانيه تعترف بمذا حاجه قطاع
الصحه والعلاج لمشاركه السيدات اذ تشكل
الشريحه الضعيفه من النساء والاطفال اكثر
من نصف المجتمع الافغاني عبد النادر
العربيه
تم مشاهدينا خلص تقرير لجنه برلمانيه الى
ان البرلمان البريطانيه بحاجه ماسه الى
اصلاح وترميم والا سيواجه خطر انهيار
حقيقي بسبب بطء عمليه الترميم ودعت اللجنه
بعد سنوات من مماطله النواب الى وضع خطه
واضحه التكلفه والجدول الزمني لانجاز
المهمه قبل فوات الاوان
مبنى البرلمان هذا على ضفافه نهر التايمز
والمطل على ساعه بيجبان من المعالم
التاريخيه الشهيره في العالم وواجهه
سياحيه لملايين السياح من كل مكان لكن هذا
الصرح مهدد بالانهيار
[موسيقى]
فتقرير للجنه المحاسبه العامه بمجلس
العموم التي تدقق في مصاريف البرلمان خلص
بان خطه الترميم المبنى الواجب اعتمادها
بطيئه في التعامل مع احداث من تسرب المطر
من السقف وسقوط قطع من البناء الى الجدران
الملوث بماده
بصحه العاملين بداخله والحرائق المتفرقه
هذا بشهادات مسؤولين على ترميم وتجديد
البرلمان المعروف بقصر وسميستر في افادتهم
امام اللجنه البرلمانيه المعنيه
امن ولكنهم متداعن في مناطق رئيسيه معينه
وبحاجه ماسه الى الترميم ومن اجل الحفاظ
على سلامته على سبيل المثال من خطر نشوب
حريق كارثي يتعين علينا القيام بدوريات
عديده حيث ليس لدينا نظام قوي لمنع اندلاع
الحرائق وانتشارها
لجنه المحاسبه تلوم سنوات من المماطله بعد
تحديد مجلس النواب قبل خمس سنوات لمسار
العمل الذي يكلف مليوني جنيه استرليني في
الاسبوع على مدى سبعه اعوام وخاصه النواب
الذين يرفضون الانتقال الى مباني اخرى ما
سيرفع تكلفه الترميم وصيانه المبنى الى
اكثر من 20 مليارا ويستغرق عشرات السنين
اذا استمرت الجلسه الصاخبه في البرلمان
اثناء عمليه الترميم
برلمانو بريطانيا ام البرلمانات في العالم
وواجهه البلاد في الخارج بنيته التحتيه
تتاكل وقد يتعرض للتدمير قبل اصلاحه ما لم
يتوقف المسؤولون والنواب عن تجاوز
المسؤوليه بشان مخاوف التكاليف الباهظه
لعمليه الترميم في زمن التقشف مصطفى زاروا
العربيه لندن
عادت حادثه مصرع الاميره البريطانيه ديانا
الى ذاكره محبيها بعد حادث مماثل تعرض له
نجله هاري وزوجته بعد مطارده سيارتهما
اثناء تتبع المصابين لهما في نيويورك حسب
ما اعلن مكتب الزوجين
كفو عن تعرضه وزوجته لمطارده شبيهه بمصرع
والدته
مصور البابارات زيتارا دوهاري وميجان
ووالدتها بسته سيارات في مدينه نيويورك
[موسيقى]
المطارده استمرت اكثر من ساعتين وشرفت على
التصادم اكثر من مره
الحادثه شبه كارثيه الشهره لا يجب ان تاتي
ابدا على حساب سلامه المرء
المطارده تعيد الى الذاكره مصرع الاميره
ديانا عام
1997 عندما قضت في احد انفاق باريس بعد
مطاردتها من قبل مصورين على دراجات ناريه
الخوف على هاري الى التخلي عن واجباته
الملكيه عام 2020 والانتقال للعيش في
كاليفورنيا
تتزايد المطالب الدوليه بوقف تطوير كل
الانظمه المتطوره تحديدا برامج محادثات
الذكاء الاصطناعي والتي باتت تشكل خطرا
كبيرا على مجتمعات وفق المشرعين
الامريكيين الذين لا يزالون يتساءلون عن
مدى تاثير تشاد على الامن القومي
برنامج محادثات الذكاء الاصطناعي يواصل
طرح المزيد من المخاوف في الاوساط العلميه
والاكاديميه من خروج خوارزميات الانظمه
المتقدمه عن السيطره وتاثيرها على حياه
الناس مطالبات في كل انحاء العالم بوقف
تطوير هذه التقنيه الحديثه التي باتت تشكل
خطرا كبيرا على المجتمعات وتنذر بعواقب
وخيمه في حال اسيء استخدامها هذا التطبيق
قد يضر العالم هو ما اكده رئيس تشاد
خلال افادته امام الكونجرس الامريكي حيث
اشار الى ان التدخل
سيكون مهما وحاسما للتخفيف من مخاطر انظمه
الذكاء الاصطناعي المتزايده بقوه وضمن
الاستراتيجيه التي من شانها وضع اطار
تنظيمي لهذا التطبيق على حد قوله تشكيل
وكاله امريكيه او عالميه ترخص انظمه
الذكاء الاصطناعي على ان تتمتع بسطه سحب
هذا الترخيص وضمان الامتثال لمعايير
السلامه وسيكون دور هذه الوكاله التنظيميه
الجديده فرض ضمانات لتنظيم عمل نماذج
الذكاء الاصطناعي التي يمكنها التكرار
والتسلسل الذاتي تشات جي بي تي التقنيه
التي حققت قفزات نوعيه ابرزها تطوير شبكات
عصبيه صناعيه تحاكي في طريقه عملها اسلوب
الدماغ البشري من خلال قدرتها على تحليل
البيانات واتخاذ القرارات طرحت ايضا قضايا
وتحديات اخلاقيه يجب مواجهتها بعد ان
توسعت لتشمل امكانيه تضليل الناس ونشر
الاكاذيب فضلا عن انتهاك حمايه حقوق الطبع
والنشر والغاء بعض الوظائف
فاليونيسكو تواصل تكثيف وتيره جهودها
لاعداد وثيقه عالميه بشان اخلاقيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي لحمايه وتعزيز حقوق الانسان وفق
قيم تخدم البشريه والانسانيه
وقع حاكم ولايه مونتانا الامريكيه غريكان
فورتي تشريعا يحضر تشغيل تطبيق مشاركه
مقاطع الفيديو القصيره لتيك توك في
الولايه وبحسب رايدر يجعل التشريع مونتانا
اول ولايه تحضر التطبيق وتمنع متاجرها
تطبيقات الهواتف المحموله من توفيره داخل
الولايه يذكر ان التطبيق المملوك لشركه
التكنولوجيا
دعوات متزايده من بعض المشارعين
الامريكيين لحظره في جميع انحاء البلاد
بسبب المخاوف المتعلقه من نفوذ الحكومه
الصينيه المحتمل على المنصه
لقي تسعه اشخاص على الاقل مسرعهم في منطقه
ايميليا رومانيا بشمال ايطاليا حيث تسببت
الامطار غزيره بفيضانات غمرت احياء واعراض
زراعيه باكملها ما ادى ايضا الى الغاء
سباق فورمولا 1 على حلبه ايمولا الذي كان
مقرر نهايه الاسبوع وتسببت الامطار
الغزيره ايضا التي انهمرت على السهول في
المنطقه على مدار يومين في فيضان نحو 20
نهرا ما ادى الى غمر مساحات شاسعه من
الاراضي بالمياه واجراء الالاف من السكان
لا سيما في مناطق تشيسينا وفورلي اللتين
تضررتا بشكل كبير جراء الفيضانات
روسيا تستهدف كييف بصواريخ كروسا
وبريطانيا تقول ان يمنع مسؤولين كبارا من
الاستقاله
امين وعامل جامعه العربيه قمه جده تشهد
عوده سوريا كعضو كامل العضويه في المنظمه
انباء عن معارك شرسه وقصيم بالطيران
بمناطق جنوب الخرطوم والمساعده الانسانيه
تتدفق لبورسودان
وزير الدفاع طالبان يعترف لا قدره دفاعيه
لنا لمواجهه المسيرات التي تسيطر على
اجواء افغانستان
نهايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا شكرا
لحسن المتابعه وفي امان الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات